The girl he was dating and the boy I was dating cheated on us with each other
and got together.
Wow.
Like guesstimate.
Yes.
What you're doing with that.
We're not going to be very good at those [inaudible]
gate there.
And how long have I been dating?
Five years.
Yeah,
it's been awhile.
It was good man.
This is five years.
Hey,
can you hear me right now?
Okay.
First Time I saw her really I was in so much pain.
It was a girl that was putting my makeup on like for the Tattoo.
Yeah.
And she was like rubbing it off all the time with alcohol as burning.
And I was like,
hey,
you gotta smile.
And so then Emily,
she was doing costumes and so she came along and she started like doing it with
makeup.
I was like,
it's a little easier cause then you take a baby wipe and wipe it away.
Scott,
like really big brown eyes and everything.
So they always looked on a happy,
oh he was tall,
dark and handsome,
which was very attractive.
I was a costume designer on almost Maine and he was actually in the show.
And I drew on his arm a tattoo every night.
He had a girlfriend at the time and had a boyfriend at the time.
So I knew that like I wasn't gonna Flirt with him or anything like that.
So we were just friends.
Take [inaudible] was you said though,
everything I said after the first question is so quiet is your attorney.
I was really upset with by the idea of like loving and women and dates in
general.
So it was part of me being like I'm not paying for a woman ever again.
Oh we went for ice cream and it was like two bucks and he was like how you guys
got to pay it?
And I was like half and half.
You pay your half.
I paid mine but then she gave me a look like no,
you're going to pay for all of it.
So I was like,
all right,
okay.
And I paid for all of it and then I like tipping like 20 bucks,
something like that.
Something ridiculous.
Cause I was like,
thanks for $2.
Talk about like our summers,
the situation and stuff and what love Mintz was.
And how it changed us and where we go from now.
And I was like,
I really want to kiss you right now.
And uh,
and then she was like,
yeah,
sure.
And then yes.
And it just stop right there.
Oh,
that was so weird.
You didn't overshare?
No.
Okay.
So this is a funny story,
but the girl he was dating and the boy I was dating cheated on us with each
other and got together.
I walked up to him and I was like,
hey,
so our x is our friends.
Uh,
maybe should,
you're like,
oh,
they're more than just friends in front of everybody.
But after that we just started texting and hanging out.
Oh,
we've pretty much been seeing each other ever since.
Okay.
Am I savagery mind?
I was already thinking,
okay,
now what I'm going to be when Emily,
that's what I'm gonna do.
And you know what,
let me say it loud.
Like they're more than friends.
I got her number and stuff.
He actually asked me out for ice cream and we're just going to hang out and uh,
actually talk about our exes because they were together now.
And so we're going to kind of compare notes and then we ended up kissing and it
became our first date.
Oh yeah.
I didn't see you tell this story.
Okay.
Why fala likes her more until,
until I hear on the phone with her friend Lauren,
or right outside my window,
not realizing that I could hear it.
Everything.
And like,
I'm like,
no,
I don't think it's,
it's not like a,
it's really nothing.
It just like a,
it was a mess with other girls.
So I didn't know.
I just got back to school.
It was like to,
Ooh,
could I do anything with
barbecue?
That is the first day back.
I didn't,
no.
You and it wasn't that day that I said that either.
It was later.
No,
I think I said it first.
You don't remember something?
What was that?
I kinda remember it.
Yeah.
I think,
yeah.
No,
no.
You don't have no idea what to answer this question real hard.
Yeah.
What will your life be like if you had never met Kevin?
Oh Gosh.
I'd probably be living in Saint Louis because that's where my mom is.
I would probably still be doing costume design cause right now I'm doing more
freelance art and visual art paintings.
Um,
cause he kind of supported my career change when we're doing stuff like this.
Okay.
Man.
Probably a lot cheaper.
Probably a lot more money.
I'll be honest.
I'll tell you right now since your ears are clogged,
if I never met him when I feel like I'd still be
angrier in a way.
I like a lot of lifestyle.
Oh Gosh.
I think I knew really soon after we started dating that I was in love with them.
Just cause like he's such a good soul and he really likes these people for who
they are.
And when we met I was going through a hard time with a breakup just like he was.
And to be seen for who I really was and what makes me unique and to not be
judged to not care.
Just to like spending time with me and want to be with me.
It,
it meant a lot and it does to this day.
It definitely means a lot to me.
Uh,
I love you because
everything I prayed for her whenever I,
uh,
thought about having a girlfriend or stuff that other girls like dinner do
literally everything.
And so,
ah,
all right,
these are real now.
But y'all going to edit this out?
Um,
I just,
we talk about how to change stuff up and it's easy to change stuff up so,
and
they're supportive like I've never had support before
and yeah,
I can't lose you because I need you
now.
We're talking about how he got real.
Most of them I saw I'd love you because
I didn't say that though olive juice is because,
oh,
I believe that too.
Then buddy over there was opening up onions and stuff.
It was crazy in here.
I surprised him.
The affect you
uh,
I just said that.
Okay,
they're gonna made me cry.
I don't know what it is.
Your emotional,
I'm going to make me cry.
Uh,
I just said that like,
yeah,
here's everything.
I prayed for his girlfriend and they're loyal and very supportive.
I said something like that,
and,
and I say,
it'll be a lot cheaper meeting without you and for me,
an artist twice New York,
and you know the deal.
Ah,
we break up right when we leave leaving
allergies.
Oh my God.
Let me baby.
That's it,
dad.
Oh my gosh.
We're not showing up this video.
Woo.
Hey,
thank you so much for watching.
I'm Landon from jubilee media.
Be sure to subscribe,
check out our Facebook and watch some more of our videos.